So in the course we discussed the
attention mechanism and we coded the
attention mechanism from scratch last
time. Here we will focus on the
transformer implementation
and we are going to use PyTorch B
belting mod modules and our focus will
be on a a staple training of uh
transformers. We will focus on a machine
translation task uh on a small data set.
Here I added an explanation.
Um the focus will be on translating
German to English. Like I said data set
is a is a small data set uh compared to
uh benchmark translation data sets like
WMT that is used in the original
transformer paper. We don't need to go
for a very large transformer
architecture and we are using a
scaledown transformer. The embedding
dimension will be 128 compared to the
original 512 in the paper by Vasvanal.
We are going to have only four heads uh
two layers in each encoder and decoders.
Um the feed forward dimension also uh we
have 500. Basically it's [snorts] four
times um wider than the model dimension.
We'll have some dropouts too. So this
will be a much smaller model like I said
compared to the original paper. The
positional encoding we will go with the
default. A review of uh multi self
attention. We will have this encoder
that is purely self attention. The
decoder has self attention of course
with causal masking. We have to make
sure uh we implement this correctly.
There will be cross attention decoder
will use for its target token to attend
to all of the source tokens. Um the
position wise feed for neural network is
a two layer with ReLU. Uh we have the
normalization after each sub layer. So
these are the hyperparameters. uh for
now of course this can be improved and
uh the training loop is just what we did
in in the past we will do the teacher
forcing and the forward pass is
basically computing the prediction for
the sequence and the loss calculation
uh is done with teacher forcing the uh
backward and the gradient clipping we
will have max norm of one and we will
validate on the held out data and we
will compute the blue score that is
basically a measure of um translation
quality. Okay, so with that let's
uh get down to coding. So here are the
imports and hyperparameters. Uh the
learning rate here I uh I choose a very
small fixed learning rate for for the
Adam optimizer but uh as you will see
for a stable training sometimes you need
to have some form of scheduling [snorts]
uh in particular warm-up scheduling. So
there are examples like gnome scheduler
that involves warm- up and decay. There
are a lot of nuances with that. I mean,
of course, training transformers are
maybe the the most challenging part of
it. Otherwise, everything else is
parallelizable and very friendly with
GPU and all of those uh goodies. But, uh
training really sometimes we should be
careful. So, here uh I don't have a lot
of issues because of the the small size
and the rather simple data set. Um but
for more challenging larger architecture
the learning rate uh scheduling is uh
very important. Okay so we have this u
gradient clipping and then we'll define
the special tokens. Okay. So I'm going
to set the seeds and then download the
data set. I will uh provide the code and
we'll be fast in this preamble parts.
Okay. So I was trying to um get a direct
link for the data set but um for some
reason I couldn't. I'm going to just
clone the repo and um and I will
describe the the path as in within this
ripple. So here is the the code on how
to handle the data set alongside some
very simple tokenization.
um for production level coding we have
to take on a better tokenization method
like for example bite pair encoding but
here we'll go with a very simple uh
tokenization okay so now that we have
the the NLP aspects aside and data is
downloaded and tokenized uh let's look
at the model architecture so first let's
uh take a look at this positional
encoding we basically fill out all of
these positions for the max length of
the sequence that we can encounter. Uh
we never get to 5,000, but let's just
make it for uh because it doesn't hurt
really. And then we will fill this up
with the sign and cosine. Uh so for now,
let's just start with the indexing of
the position. We are going to do a range
from zero. We need this to be a float
because I'm going to use it for
calculating the encoding frequencies.
The magic formula for
uh calculating the frequencies is this.
And [snorts]
now for the even and odd positions we
will so even will be will get sign and
odds will get cosine. So we have to be
careful for example if d model is um odd
we have to take care of that. But here I
mean it's very rare to have odd uh D
model. So let's not do transpose for
now. And then let's register this
encoding as a buffer. So basically it's
saved it will be saved with the model
state and we are not going to treat it
like a trainable parameter. So the
optimizer is not going to train this.
Okay. So that's it and let's write the
forward.
So what we did here is we basically add
the positional encoding to the input
tensor X and we sliced the encoding up
to the um actual sequence length of X.
If you remember we had this additional
uh positions that is not uh necessary.
So we only use as much as we want. Okay.
So that's that and let's write the
transformer model class. Okay. So let's
give some default values just to maybe
simplify our life. Um I said 21 28 and
heads uh we chose four we chose four and
layers two
feet forward uh dimension 512
and drop out was.1.
Okay. So that's that and let's define a
few things. Same for the decoder
embedding. Okay, that's embedding and
let's do the positional encoding and we
are ready to define the structure of the
um one single encoder layer, right? So
I'm going to use the the native
um pietorch uh function just for
simplicity. We already uh did all of the
coding of the attention from the
scratch. So here we will focus on the
training. So Dmodel and has the feed
forward dimension drop out. And here I
want to add this um batch first true
since our data may be a form of batch
and sequence length and embedding
dimension. So doesn't hurt to have this.
So we will set this to true. Okay. So
that's that. And now we stack the layers
using this. And then now we can look at
the decoder stack. And as you see, we
get all of these suggestions, which
basically means how standard is this
code. And that's pretty much for it for
the stack of encoder and decoder. And
now we can do the output projection for
the generator of the tokens. I see the
suggestion is pretty much what I want.
Good. Um, let's just be more explicit
here. I'll put projection.
Okay, great. So now we need to
initialize the parameters and to do that
we have to write a function for it but
let's just put a placeholder for now
um init parameters which we don't have
yet. So we have to write it. So diff
init parameters which of course we know
it's very important to initialize the
parameters in a way that u help in the
stability of the training. For here we
are going to use heavier uh
initialization to keep the variance of
the outputs consistent across all of the
layers. This prevents the signals from
vanishing or exploding uh when they are
propagating through the network. Okay.
So for pin self.parameters parameters.
Um we basically do in it have your
uniform but it's always a good practice
to say if P is more than a scalar do
that otherwise it's not necessary so
have your uniform is good. Okay. So what
else we want? So we need to write a
forward method of course and within the
forward method we have the for metaphor
um that goes through the encoder and
decoder. one thing that we need to
before so we need to write this for our
method of course like I said but for now
let's just go back here and uh uh we
want um causal mask because we need that
in the forward we need to basically we
want to prevent decoder from looking
ahead and not cheat so in pietorch uh
and and transformer
uh for any modules there For positions
that we want to be ignored uh or masked
out uh we will mark them as true or
minus infinity. And uh let's do that. So
generate a square subsequent mask. Yes.
And
yep we want to define a mask which is a
upper triangular
and
the upper triangular elements gets one.
We also give one to diagonals and we out
a boolean. Okay. So we set the diagonals
also to zero because we want to
basically say everything above the
triangle
we want it to be one and then later we
get the boolean which returns true for
them. So the they will be masked right
and then after that we can return the
mask. Okay. So now we can go ahead and
write the forward method. We already
have the causal mask so we can use it.
We don't we don't need a source mask. So
let's just write the target mask. Okay.
So note that this is the length of the
the target. Maybe we can make it more
explicit. And of course the the device.
So this is basically the causal mask for
the target sequence. And now let's uh
work through the padding masks. Okay. So
source padding mask
what we have here. Let's just keep them
as is for now. So basically we're
telling the the PyTorch to ignore the
paddings here. Okay. So now we can do
the embedding. Um so source
embed
and that's that we have this positional
encoding of the source and uh target. So
in the original paper the authors
recommend scaling the embedding by the
square root of d model. Let's uh let's
do that too just to stick with the
original formulation. Okay. So that's
that. And now we have the encoder
uh that processes the source
uh sentence. It only needs the source
padding mask. So that's the output of
the encoder. I'm going to call this
memory
which is the sequence that we encode uh
the German sequence here.
And now the output
from the decoder that uses this target
embedding takes in the encoder output or
the memory and all of the masks that we
made. So remember that this is the
causal mask. Now we uh we can return the
projected output. So um to evaluate the
translation task we can add a function
that can compute the blue score. So in
the past we used the the standard torch
text
uh but that's uh duplicate that's now uh
is not used anymore.
Uh here we can just implement this uh
manually. I'm going to do this quickly
but I will provide the code for you. Oh,
I see I made a mistake here. Let's go
back. Yep.
Oh, so let's give it a name to avoid
that issue. See, we forgot a parenthesis
here, here,
and we're good. Okay, so here we have
the blue score computation. Let's just
separate them. Uh I will add more
commentation for you. Okay, that's that.
And let's move on to uh some functions
for the inference and the evaluation
functions. Okay. So the inference or the
translate here takes in the model, the
source sentence, the source vocabulary,
the target vocabulary and the the source
tokenizer. Remember that. Um and we need
some form of like max length. Okay. So
this will be during inference. So model
val
and
here we have to prepare the source
tensor which requires uh adding
um um beginning of the sentence uh index
and uh indices of the
sentence tokens plus at the end we have
to uh add a end of sentence uh token for
the source uh sentence and then we need
to convert it to a tensor and send it to
the device. Okay. So source indices
uh first the POS
idx
we see source vap numericalize source
sentence source tokenizer plus end of
sentence idx and then source tensor.
Okay. So I went for more familiar
version for the target sequence. We just
need the first token to start with which
is beginning of the sentence. It's like
the initial point of generation of the
sentence. So that's the target for now
and the model will populate that. Okay.
So with torsograph and for the max
length of the sentence of course it will
stop when we encounter the end of
sentence. So we need to have an if next
token is EOS idx we have to stop this
for loop um so the target so let's just
write now why not so if next token is
end of send idx we want to break it so
let's go back here
um maybe we don't need that for now we
will write it so output is that here it
takes in the source and the current
target at this step. So this is
basically the the step of the auto
reggressive generation. So we have this
TGT tensor or the target tensor that we
will append to each time we will append
the next token. Okay. [clears throat] So
let's um compute that next token which
is the output uh arg max and that
basically pops the item and we append
the next token to the target indices.
Okay. We check if it is EOS.
If it is EOS, stop the auto reggressive
generation. If not, continue doing this.
And now we we have to convert these
indices back to tokens because here the
argmax looks at the priority
distribution corresponding to each one
of these indices and choose the one that
uh is the maximum or the most probable.
Uh there's no creativity here in this
translation job. It's a greedy decoding.
We may get a better translation if we do
a beam search. Uh but let's uh just do
the the vanilla greedy decoding. And
here we convert the indices to tokens.
So we are decoding the sequence of the
target token indices into the strings.
To do that we have to run it against the
vocabulary of the target. And uh we have
to skip the beginning of the sentence
token and then look at each one of these
indices to get the corresponding
vocabulary. If we find it good if not we
will just assign an unknown token to it.
So this is how we are doing it. So
target vocap index to string mapping
which is index 2 string mapping get idx
and if the index isn't found return uh
unknown. So we need to do this for all
of this idx in the target indices. We
don't need to do it for the beginning of
the sentence. So let's just skip that.
And also we we may need to remove the
end of sentence if we encountered it
here. Okay. So for that we just check if
the last token equals end of sentence
and we slice the last one. Good. Okay.
So then we can return the target
sequence which we need to join all of
these tokens. So to do that it's enough
to do this to evaluate this uh sentence
this translated sentence we will
calculate the blue score and it is
important of course to do it in an auto
reggressive uh decoding way just like
the translation function. So no teacher
forcing here otherwise the evaluation
will not be correct. So I'm going to
write the the function here and then we
can move on to the training loop.
Okay. So here I started with uh
preparing the data set first downloading
the data and then doing the tokenization
and building the vocabulary. Um I'm
going to only build vocabulary for those
um tokens that appear at least two
times. So frequency threshold uh we are
setting it to two. Then we can build
this vocabulary. Same for the target.
Okay. Now we can set the data set and
data loader. Okay. So then the train
loader and the validation loader going
to accept the suggestion. Move on and
then we can initialize the model. So
model transformer.
Okay. Let's see what we have. Number of
heads and then have n layers dimension
of bit forward and the dropout. That's
it. uh we can send it to device looking
good. And then what else we need? We
need um let's print the number of
parameters. It's always good. And then
uh we will set the criterion uh which is
a cross entropy which we need to ignore
the padding indexes and then we can set
up the atom. So cross entropy last that
has to ignore padding indices. Now the
optimizer which is Adam. So torch
optimadam takes in the model parameters
and the learning rate. Okay. So now we
can write the forward loop. Uh let me
just track the best blue score since so
far during the forward loop starting
from zero and then four epoch in range
of n apoch. You already know this. I'm
going to be fast. Uh we'll skip most of
this. Okay. So this within an epoch we
look at the batches of the sequences. Um
during the training we are doing teacher
forcing. So the input to the decoder is
a target sequence shifted right. So
starting with bos and then excludes the
last token. So let's do that. So the
target input and the expected output is
the target sequence starting from the
first real world. Uh so we exclude WS
the target output DGT. Okay. So let's
zero the optimizer
and do a forward.
So the output
is the model source target loss
criterion.
Okay. So uh here notice that I did some
reshaping. The output was of this shape
and we are converting it to batch times
sequence and vocabulary size and we also
reshape the target to be so initially it
is here is batch and sequence we are
reshaping it to batch time sequence. So
that's what we did and that's the last
and now we can do the backward here the
gradient clipping uh the optimizer step
we can do the validation of that epoch
for the evaluation I believe eval loss
for now zero let's compute this
validation loss within the validation
data so with the torch no grad we
basically want to calculate the
validation loss we are going to use
teacher forcing and then uh we will
compute um at the blue score. So blue
score computation is a bit heavy. We
only do it uh at the end of the epoch
and then we do some logging. We only
save the model the best model based on
the blue score. So that's what I'm going
to write. I will skip that for the most
part. We'll add some codes for the
logging of the during the epoch also.
Let's do it here. Okay. So I think we
have uh most of the things in place and
um here we do a qualitative check for
just a few sample sentences randomly
generated really. I did some error
checking and now oh okay it looks like
things are working. So now we can uh
activate our
CUDA.
We we already get some interesting
translation. The blue score is rather
good here. I mean 21 is is good. Uh, of
course the data set is easy. It's not a
very complex data. Um, but we already we
are on a good track and maybe we can
kill this training after blue score of
around 30 35. So another jump in blue
score 29 which I'm pretty happy with.
And uh almost all of the translations
are looking good. And um yeah, so the
training continues, but we can stop the
video.